Wow I intended to do this
the first video in English and yeah when
I got Cape Elena Bridge which one would
you seek arrow of Nakamura so it's about
the toughest test you can get on a sec
especially as I'm I'm very reliable to
play rather slowly and it's about the
fastest player on earth so let's see
what happens he opened with f4 and I
must admit um while being a little bit
in shock that I got to play him I'd show
some setup that I have no idea about but
well maybe maybe it's it's not so bad
while this night is served a little bit
misplaced for sure I'm not sure what
what's the proper route from the night I
could I could get it to to f6 perhaps
well at least it should be better than
an h6 and it doesn't look like white
should have anything particularly
threatening it's got some space
advantage but yes okay well I think he
would like like me to exchange on b3 to
improve the the palm position but if I
go to d3 I think I will get the bishop
on c1 and indeed I will not sure of its
own such a huge accomplishment but well
Bishop is a bishop okay maybe threatened
h4 to undermine f4 of course he has seen
this but now I've got some square on g4
yeah the question is do I want to
exchange this bishop not sure I've got
the bishop a bit not sure how much it is
worth
okay I'll take on a three
one thing you absolutely know that at
the end of the day you will be quicker
than you so at some at some point you
have to speed ups just to to to get a
game and not to lose some time with 100%
certainty
yeah not sure maybe actually b5 with the
idea to play route besides got the
square square now I didn't I didn't see
this
yeah you know this is getting a bit
uncomfortable do I want to to take this
I don't think so
well not not at the moment at least yeah
it's got c4 now
Pietro runs internal 96
and sure see for maybe I should just
drop back but then he's got 96 well I
take it and drop back yeah yeah okay
this is a nice position for white for
sure you really outplayed me
yeah not just six Oh
but
time warning
do do do I have Roxy well no idea but
passive move will lose for sure at least
sometime
J
well 92 King D 1
check
you know it's got another seven oh well
well nice nice to play Doctor Who I once
again okay every son black resigns yeah
well he played quickly this was no
surprise it's actually hard to tell at
which point the position really really
got bad
well maybe be 5v5 was some was wrong I
didn't really take into account that he
couldn't can just return to be three and
then put this night on so far but by
looking at it and why do I did not place
he fired myself Wow this this is this is
awful I can just play see for myself
what's the problem it could quick check
with computer just just to make sure you
know it doesn't see anything as well and
gives white 0.3 advantage with but it's
basically nothing
yeah the position shouldn't be that bad
if if I play c5 where it doesn't have
anything anything special I think
yeah this is a missed chance what if
what would have to work hard I guess
after c5 well most likely the time
factor would have become very important
but um this um this really really helps
wide and still a pretty solid position
but it's just ajust a one way game from
here
yeah a for a fall
I could have played I played this one
move later you still computer suits the
things 95 is equal which is possible
certainly maybe rooks III was was just a
panic move
yeah in 95 look-see pretty much okay
the variation given by the deaney engine
for instance just leads to exchange of
all the queenside pawns and it's hard to
imagine that black would lose such a
position well one problem could be f7 I
had one at one point but at some yeah 95
well I guess this was just over I'm just
a quick look but would be surprising
yeah yeah he just he just gets on the 7
thought so
yeah okay this was a nice start for the
for the for the English comentary